so if you're writing to a CEO like think
like a CEO would like to be spoken to
right and to your point Simplicity hey
which by the way is one of the most
successful subject lines in the history
of like email prospecting because it
seems like it's personal it's coming
from someone that you may want to have a
conversation with and then you go
straight to the point like you don't
need to say like hey we just went
through the YC we raised all this money
like you lost me at that point and all
of that is is sort of the structure that
you use for posting online for doing
copy for newsletters it's it's really
that hook at the beginning to say like
how can I help you or we build this
um should we talk
all right guys bang bang I thought a
great place for us to start this
conversation is the idea of Founders
when they start a business everyone
wants to build a business but they don't
realize that not only are you the
founder the CEO probably the engineer
but also you have to be the sales person
and sales is this thing that everyone
kind of feels like is uh something they
don't want to do but like how do I get
customers how do I drive revenue and so
let's just start with like when the
founder has to do the sales what have
you seen as the best practices or what
are the things that they can do to
increase the odds of success as that
first salesperson great question Tom
thanks for having me first of all but I
think that um the best Founders that
I've worked with uh throughout my career
have a phenomenal way to do sales they
have the most passion they build the
product they know how to do it but
essentially what they do is you know get
in front of the right customers through
the proper channels so what does that
mean in in a world of founder-led sales
you're juggling a lot of things as you
say the CEO has to find a way to get in
front of customers where they live and
where they live means you know if you're
selling into engineering you're not
necessarily going to call an engineer
because they don't typically like to
talk on the phone but let's say if
you're you have an HR product you're
going to find a way to build a good
email sequence or maybe a LinkedIn
presence that is going to help you get
in front of them the second thing is you
know a lot of Founders educate
themselves right so sales has a stigma
as you say but it is the forcing
function for growth for any type of
business so the founders that understand
that and that are truly seeking to one
get feedback and two help somebody solve
a problem usually happen to be the most
successful in this domain early in the
company and so when they're going and
finding where those people are like walk
me through the process so let's just say
that we built a piece of software and uh
we're trying to sell to Engineers sure
uh how do I go figure out where are the
engineers do I just like go talk to a
bunch of them online and say like hey
what do you do all day and figure it out
that way or like is there a process
that's repeatable that people can say
okay if I built a company or a product
how do I find where my customers are
yeah so there's a couple of avenues and
um what most people will do is if if you
come out of Y combinator for example
there's a network so you try to find a
low hanging fruit who you know what what
uh distribution you know channels you
can get easiest to but also what a lot
of companies will do is final Target
list and the process to finding that
Target list is really part of ideating
your go to market strategy which means
like here's who I think I can solve a
problem for that usually is the person
or the buyer Persona and then the ideal
customer profile which means the person
or the business that that operates you
know within that person today it's much
easier than it was 10 years ago to find
access to those uh let's say lists of
people companies like Apollo Lucia ample
market sales uh assume info or sales
Loft will give you access to a data set
that is aligned with what you've decided
as your target buyer and then from there
what's important is how do you build the
right copy or how do you get in front of
them in a way that is interesting
and that's differentiated because
there's so much noise nowadays
everyone's doing emails everyone's
sending you know kind of Outreach
messages through Linkedin so it's really
finding you know kind of that sweet spot
in that honest message coming from a CEO
and maybe perhaps going to to another
founder that has that problem so plenty
of Founders will say like okay it's time
for me to do sales let me write up this
like six paragraph email that explains
exactly what I do tells you every single
detail you need to know uh in my
experience like actually maybe just
sending like hey we did X it'll save you
money do you want to talk right like
three sentences yeah actually may have a
better response rate how do you think
about copy and like how professional to
be whether the emails should be like
really beautiful and have you know a
bunch of uh images and things like that
or they should just be plain text like
we're starting to get into the
nitty-gritty of actually you know
reaching out to these people but like
what have you seen these either best
practice or what is the process at which
people can figure out uh and test to get
to what works for them yeah that's a
great question and I love that you say
that because I'm sure you want to be
spoken to in the way that you speak to
others right and as a Founder you
probably or CEO of all the businesses
that you have you don't have time to go
through like a sophisticated like
lengthy message and you're gonna get
lost so like the longer messages usually
don't have the best conversion rates
what messages usually are most
successful is when you understand the
person on the other end of you know kind
of the email so if you're writing to a
CEO like think like a CEO would like to
be spoken to right and to your point
Simplicity hey which by the way is one
of the most successful subject lines in
the history of like email prospecting
because it seems like it's personal it's
coming from someone that you may want to
have a conversation with and then you go
straight to the point like you don't
need to say like hey we just went
through the YC we raised all this money
like you lost me at that point and all
of that is is sort of the structure that
you use for posting online for uh doing
copy for newsletters it's it's really
that hook at the beginning to say like
how can I help you or We Built This
should we talk and then when you get
someone and they respond how much of
this is the founders getting on phone
calls can it be done over email like
what do you see in terms of uh okay I
put out all this bait I got a couple
bites now right like what is the process
from that point yeah so I think it
really depends on the stage of the
company and also like the size of the
deal right so if it's an early stage
company the founder benefits from being
part of any type of conversation I want
to know what the market wants and I want
to know what type of feedback everyone
is giving me with regards to what I'm
trying to solve for so I guess to
directly answer a question like a
Founder would want to be on every single
call like in the early days and you know
if you have any other like sales staff
sure you can have them maybe qualify
that opportunity in a light way but you
know try to get as much information as
possible and answer them as quickly as
possible so you can you know kind of get
the ball rolling and get into the sales
process itself and then when they are in
that process they're obviously learning
right from potential customers
um how much of this is just like the
founders are passionate about what
they're doing and they're good versus
they should have scripts and they should
practice and they should kind of have
what I'll consider a more uh intentional
sales process even though it's still
just the founder doing the sales
themselves I love that question because
it's where a lot of Founders miss out on
the most and I'll explain why um typical
Founders are more on the technical side
right they're the ones that can code
they have a lot of sophistication from a
technical capacity they don't
necessarily have that much exposure
experience on the commercial side so
they try to over engineer sales and when
you over engineer sales you sort of lose
that human component and you know in
selling what you want to do is have a
human connection ask the right questions
understand the other guy and make sure
that you have a product that can solve
their problems and that Simplicity is
sometimes forgotten and when people try
to do scripts too early on you know they
sort of miss out on a lot the basic
thing that I can think of you know that
most uh early stage Founders will do is
sure they'll have an agenda they'll have
a structure and a process but the beauty
is in the questions that you can ask
them to understand like where they stand
what they need and based off that then
you tell them about your product with
their needs in mind so ask questions yes
have them tell you the answers to the
test before you take the test is
basically the the big lesson 100 and and
I mean it's sort of like people joke
about this if it's like a seller has
like two years in one mouth so you're
supposed to listen more than you
actually talk there's there's a ratio
within like you know kind of sales
enablement that's the talk to listen
ratio and supposedly it's like you know
if if you listen more than what you talk
you have a better percentage of closing
the deal which is a huge you know kind
of uh breaking of a misconception
because people historically think that
the best sellers are the ones that don't
shut up and it's the complete opposite
and when you're asking these questions
how much of them are uh I'll call it
open-ended questions like hey tell me
about your problem right and just kind
of sit back and listen versus it is uh
questions that are very specific what is
your budget for this specific type of
product what is the timeline to make a
decision like is there a combination of
open-ended and kind of more direct
questions or is there uh each one's
different talk to me about like the
types of questions that people are
asking I I mean sounds like you know
about this but uh the earlier in the
sales process
um the more open-end that you want to be
because the the Tactical thing is that
you can't interrogate a buyer right
they're going to feel interrogated and
they're going to say like you're wasting
my time or show me the product right so
let's go so what you want to do is uh
sit down and pick five open-ended
questions that can give you as much
information as possible and so for
example help me understand what are your
you know kind of short-term goals in
terms of Revenue right so if I'm selling
a product that impacts you know let's
say top line revenue I wanna I wanna
understand like how they're going to get
there and what challenges or what's in
the way and I give them a question that
can give as much information as possible
so I can use it to my advantage when I
am talking about the product layer down
the road
so
I put out bait I get bites I get on the
first call I do a great job I shut up
after asking my open-ended questions I
get a bunch of information uh and then I
say okay I'm gonna send you follow-up
information yep what the hell am I
supposed to send right again this is
just the founder we don't have a sales
team yet sure so is it uh here's a link
to a demo is it a uh presentation is it
a sign up form like what is kind of the
best practice there and then as a second
part to this what do I do if they don't
respond yeah yeah the the uh hated
follow-up you know hell that you get
kind of thrown into what is the best
practice for a Founder so a lot of that
is is a result of not doing a good job
on the first call and let me explain so
when you go on a first call and you have
an okay conversation you send the
product and you sort of see that the
person is not as excited that's when you
go into murky Waters and I'll tell you
why because what typically happens is
that you'll end the call with something
like hey thanks for your time you know
let me send you some follow-up
information in I'll check in with you in
a couple weeks that is where you get
into the deal chasing territory was not
a good place to be now what you want to
do is if you have a good call which
you're asking the right questions and
there is mutual interest you want to
propose The Next Step before you leave
the call right and my best practice is
usually like have something on calendar
for your next meeting so you avoid the
they went dark or like they're stuck in
my CRM after my first call and I can't
get a hold of him because you want to
make sure that there's like that Mutual
benefit but also you're driving the deal
to the next place but assuming that you
did a great job with presenting an
opportunity that you know is something
that will provide value to them and
let's say that you do have that calendar
invite set up this happened to me before
and I was like I don't know what to do
yeah and then they hey I gotta
reschedule okay and then you basically
get another one and then they reschedule
again it almost feels like they're using
the reschedule as a way to keep kicking
the can down the road sure what do you
suggest in terms of actually being able
to be effective and follow-up without
annoying people yeah
um so there's a global tactics um I'll
go back to how well you execute that
first call
um I think you know if you execute that
right call
you can find out ways that they actually
have some sort of urgency so going back
to my Revenue example if they're trying
to get to an X number of Revenue by
let's say the end of the year the sooner
you guys start working together the
sooner I can help you get to that goal
right so what I try to find out in the
first call is is that you know kind of
urgency lover so I can keep it in mind
as as with regards to follow-up so
you're saying like hey if you want to
get this implemented let's say by August
31st in order for us to do that we need
to make sure that we go through X number
of steps and instead of being annoying
what I'll do is I'll remind them of what
happened in that call like Hey listen I
think we had a great conversation just
want to make sure I'm not being the
annoying sales rep but um understanding
that you have a goal or deadline doesn't
make sense to you know have a call
sooner than instead of two weeks later
down the road right um that's one the
second one is I'm a big fan of something
that's called the call between the call
so when you call someone and assuming
they answer
between the scheduled calls that person
is not necessarily prepared to have a
conversation with you so naturally and
humanistically they will give you the
honest answer right so you call them and
say like hey Pop
um you know I know we we have a call you
know kind of next Thursday you know give
me a sense of you know kind of how you
felt about the product you know does
this really align with what you're
looking for and hopefully in that
scenario you tell me like listen you're
good but you know you're a little bit
out of budget and then we can you know
know what to address at that situation
got it and so are you calling them on
their cell phone or like just trying to
catch them off guard essentially pretty
much I mean it's um whatever the tactics
all the tactics are right yeah and so
when you're calling though is it just
like you know hey Steve hey Mary uh I
got two seconds
um you know I just wanna hear what you
thought about the product or is it
something that is much more uh kind of
polished like how do you normally
approach those calls it has to be as
human and as like straightforward as
possible so if I'm calling you to say
like hey pump you know what did you
think about you know kind of my product
I you know I'm excited about this
opportunity
you know you think that we're you know
on the right track if if for example I
forgot to ask this question that that's
something that I'll use as an
opportunity I forgot to ask you this
question on the call but I wanted to you
know catch you one-on-one
um is this something that you think uh
is worthwhile or you know you see as as
getting you closer to your goals and
then what about like identifying who the
champion is internally right so
sometimes in my experience the champion
is the decision maker other times
they're not the decision maker but how
do you if you've got a couple of
different people you're talking to a
company how do you kind of identify okay
that is going to be the champion and
then how do you treat them differently
than maybe you may treat other people
yeah so great question I think that it's
more obvious than you think in a sense
of like being able to ask right so who
is uh who is going to be the person
that's going to sign on the dotted line
um who needs to be part of the decision
making process those types of questions
a lot of like sales reps or even
Founders in the early days like forget
or fear asking but it's as simple as
understanding you know how do you
transact and let me align to the way
that you transact right and and a lot of
times they might just give you the
answer and say like hey I'm going to be
the one that's you know kind of making
the decision but we have a panel of
people et cetera Etc how you treat that
person is hopefully in a more
um personal way right I want to build
the relationship with that person and if
I'm the one being the founder calling I
will make the call out of the champion I
won't make the call to the economic
buyer or somebody else right it's tough
sometimes because it's a champion may be
the CEO CEO is not necessarily going to
be available to pick up a column you
know 3 P.M on a Tuesday afternoon so you
have to be strategic about it what about
um once you've got as a Founder yeah the
decision maker says yeah we're good to
go and then it gets sent to finance
or it gets sent to compliance or you
know the the uh general counsel there's
a couple of different organizations
internally usually that have to kind of
touch whatever the contract is or review
something and now you feel like you've
almost been separated from the champion
being able to manage the process to like
hey it's with Finance hey it's with you
know uh compliance yeah how could you as
a Founder continue to help move this
forward without being annoying yeah so
that is very typical in Enterprise sales
right so when you're selling to a bigger
organization I think that the important
thing for you to understand is that that
will happen right so a lot of people go
into these sales processes like
expecting it to be signed off
um you know and and that is where you
lose time and where you lose momentum
right so if I know that I'm gonna have
to go through legal clients Finance
sometimes even vendor risk I want to
start addressing those as early as
possible in the sales process so I know
that I need to go down that route and
that I'm going to do it in a either
parallel fashion as we're like agreeing
to business terms and then doing the
logistical work right so sometimes what
reps will do or early stage Founders is
they'll they'll create a mutual action
plan and in that Mutual action plan
there's pretty much sort of a timeline
of the things that we assume that need
to be covered and that actually shows a
lot of preparation from like the seller
side because you know you want to do
business with someone that knows what
they're doing right so if someone shows
up and tells me like hey pom but here's
usually how we sell into Enterprise
customers and we're able to go through
agreeing on the business terms going to
committee going to Legal going to
compliance and here are the different
dates that we want to you know kind of
agree to what typically happens in
something like that process is that you
also have a date that you solve back
from right so if it's going to take me a
month to be in finance and we need to
get the deal done you know within three
weeks I'm going to go back to my
champion and let them know what the
process is like because I want to make
sure that they can deliver the urgency
because in both of our best interests
for it to move forward and then I use
that champion to gain some velocity on
the finance side or maybe he needs to go
nudge someone because being the champion
also means that he can help me you know
Lobby or work the internals of that
heavy or big organization
now that the founder has made a couple
of sales and starts to understand the
process eventually they'll say okay I
need to hire someone I've talked to
Founders and they're like all sales
people are full of [__] right and they
can't sell it all yeah and then I've
talked to other Founders that are like
build as big of a sales team as you
possibly can they're amazing and they
all Drive Revenue yeah uh the truth's
probably somewhere in between sure but
how do you think about that first or
second sales hire where do you find
these people and how as a Founder can
they actually uh interview and kind of
underwrite who's good and who may not
you know be able to deliver on the
promises that they say yeah so the
founding account executive as I like to
call it or it's known in the industry is
one of the hardest hires to make early
in in in in a company's you know journey
and I'll tell you why it's because
you're going from the founder-led sales
motion to starting you know kind of that
sales LED growth motion meaning sales is
leading the charge but you're
transferring all the information from
the person that build the product that
knows his best and actually has the most
passion into someone that you want to
make sure that has the same skill set or
like passion for what they're selling so
this is a very non-traditional sales
role and I can tell you a lot about it
because I was a founding account
executive which you can talk about more
it's more a seller that wants to build
but that can overly communicate and I'll
explain why when you're trying to find
that velocity that you know scalability
and repeatability in the early days when
you're past the Baton from the founder
to a seller you still need to report
back to the engineering team you still
need to tell the engineering team Hey
listen like I know this is our roadmap
but what I'm hearing in the market and
what people are telling me that they
want is X Y or Z and so you're giving
you're putting a lot of responsibility
from a company's perspective into
someone that's you know kind of external
now that person because I mentioned he
is a builder must want to have that
ability to work outside of like you know
sales conversations or like maybe
non-revenue generating activities which
maybe talk into engineering that person
also must want to build and they must be
willing to be in an environment where
there's a lot of uncertainty but nothing
is put together
so I'll tell you what an example of like
a founding account executive that
usually doesn't work is someone that
comes from a really large organization
and goes into an early stage environment
and I'll explain because in a larger
organization you have marketing you have
sales engineering that's usually the one
that's doing the presentations or the
product demos you have you know a brand
behind you that you may not have in the
early days and when you put that same
exact person that's used to just
transacting with a team behind them into
an early stage environment where they
don't have that you know infrastructure
or support behind them they usually get
overwhelmed and you know they they can
perform right so that's the very long
answer to the first part of your
question I think that from an interview
process
it has to be the founder identifying
someone that is a lot of entrepreneurial
but a lot of selling right and there are
many ways to catch I get this all the
time sales people interview well but in
real they don't if you ask the right
questions right because they're
everyone's happy everyone's peppy et
cetera and whatnot but what you got to
understand is number one like why do you
want to go early stage like what do you
want to go into like the most uncertain
sales environment possible number two is
like what's your willingness and give me
examples of like how would you build
this and send me the examples and then
three I usually like to do situational
questions right so let's say somebody
called you to tell you that you suck or
you know something along those lines or
maybe it's a deal that I want them to
walk me through because I want to find
alignment too I want to find that
someone that has been in a particular
sales environment can actually translate
over and if they've sold into actually
the same buyer Persona that this company
is now selling into that's even better
because they can help us accelerate and
they know exactly what to do so one of
the things that you're highlighting here
that many people probably just don't
think about until they're in in it is
that first sales hire they also have to
create all the sales material right they
have to create uh the deck they have to
create uh what is the demo going to look
like what is all of our email sequences
Etc and in my experience
um there are some people who are amazing
at sales they hate prospecting right and
they're like hey at my last job like
just like you know leads showed up and I
went and I sold and I was amazing at it
but like I don't know how to go get the
leads yeah uh and there's even people
who are really good at prospecting and
they're like well I've never been on
sales call before yep right I just went
and found all the leads and gave them to
somebody else and so it really almost
feels like you need somebody can go kind
of full funnel and find leads have the
materials the system the all the
follow-up sequences Etc and then also be
able to actually close the deal as well
yep
how many of those are out there right
like are there a lot of those people out
there or is this actually like a pretty
hard role to find it's hard it's hard
it's a hard roll to find
um and you open up a question or a
situation where you know traditionally
B2B SAS as you mentioned there's the SDR
that's doing the prospecting you know
kind of full force and there's an
account executive that's just doing the
demos closing negotiation Etc
um I think that there is a world where
the founding account executive like
needs to be full sales cycle rep but
also that the full sales cycle rep is
something that is going to come and be
more prevalent like in this day and age
and let me explain why
um there are so many tools out there
today that help you create a system to
prospect that allow you to get uh access
to information or leads very easily and
with AI and all the different things
that we can go into
um it's even easier to write good copy
and to you know make it more
personalized to that particular person
so if you create the right systems which
obviously require a level of savviness
from like that individual you're going
to create your own momentum to to get
leads right and then second to that
which you see a lot of of reps doing on
LinkedIn nowadays is creating your own
personal brand creating a lot of content
that can you know give you that audience
so when you do Prospect there's a
perception of like this guy is well
known I've seen you before I want to
talk to you right so that skill set is
hard to find right someone that wants to
go through the through the whole process
not only wants to but has the tools to
actually do process expecting and
closing altogether the reason a lot of
companies historically will do sdrnas
because of focus because when you're
prospecting you're not transacting and
when you're not transacting you're
prospecting so it's really important
that like that and that first sales
higher the founding account executive
has the right system right to to create
top of the funnel if you haven't created
it yet which again requires a particular
sales muscle and then the separate sales
muscle which is like how do I structure
the sales process and iterate every day
as the founder you've now hired someone
you think they're good
um how can you be a good manager and
then what are the things that you could
do to really [__] it up right like like
you've got the sales person there yeah
uh there's got to be some trust sure
right but like what are some of the
things that are like best practices of
managing that first sales person and
then what are the things that just
please avoid because you're going to
make it the situation worse
I think you know micromanaging for any
role is is what you know kills any sales
rep no sales reps wants to have someone
on top of their stuff you know kind of
on a regular basis that's number one
um I think that you know wanting the
sales person to specifically operate on
their a particular style is a way that
you can break a rep and I'll tell you
why some reps are phenomenal on the
phone some are not and some reps are
extremely good at email some are not
now I cannot it's sort of like you know
get your job done however you can get it
done like I'll respect it but you know
many times the founder will say no no
you have to make you know a thousand
calls this week and this rep may not
necessarily be good on the phone now you
need to know that ahead of time because
if you're trying to sell to a buyer that
needs to be communicated through on the
phone you just make the wrong hire
that's no that's that's super important
as well right but you need to give them
you know kind of the respect to what
their style is in a sense of like here's
how you execute but also give them the
right direction
um sales is very grueling it's intense
you get a lot of rejection so I think
that as a manager you also have to
support a lot of like your team and
remind them why they're here or why
they're good because a lot of times like
they will be defeated because it's it's
a grueling job with a lot of pressure
deadlines goals Etc
and
I think the last thing I'll say is is
um you know you mentioned trust I think
that's one of the most important things
when a rep knows that they're they're
not being trusted I mean it's a hard
situation to be in but also at the end
of the day sales is black and white
you're a performing or you're not so
so I've done it in the past
um somebody smarter than me told me
they're like higher two at a time yeah
don't just hire one AE don't just hire
one SDR hire two at the same time and
then in some ways uh there's this like
implicit competition yeah so they kind
of bring their a game yep but there's
also this like explicit uh almost like
um kind of social safety net of like
emotional support because you're not
there by yourself trying to figure out
all this you have somebody to talk to
Etc is that the best practice is to kind
of hire two at a time you're spot on
you're spot on I'll tell you why
um you know a salesperson is used to
being around a team when you take them
out of that environment and you put them
in an environment where he's by himself
it's tough not everyone's built to be a
lone wolf so when you hire two you know
you give them that social let's say
belonging but you're also solving for
you know performance sometimes when you
have
um two reps you might see that one is
better than the other or one figured it
out the other day didn't and what a lot
of companies will do is they'll just
hire one and say well this guy can't
sell he's a sales guy we don't have a
good product that's a tough decision to
make just based off the performance of
one individual but when you have two
individuals and two performance let's
say metrics that you can compare it
makes life a little bit more
understanding to say like well if this
guy works like that means that we have
we have a solution we we can sell how do
we get more people and creative process
that then we keep adding more to the
process when do you know when to fire
them
everyone has their own you know kind of
way to do this but um usually there's
like a ramp period uh three months right
so you could give them soft goals you
say like you know by month one you have
to do what I think is 25 of your goal
month two you have to do 50 on your goal
and month three you're fully ramped
which means it's at the ex what I think
you can sell you know you're selling
that by month three
um if that person hasn't or you see that
they don't have you know kind of the
right uh let's say performance with
those metrics it's time to go so I'll
give you a real life example I think of
how some of this gets very complex we
have a business
um they're five figure contracts uh
they're with pretty large businesses
um and we'll get verbal uh commitments
yep we're in send us the contract we're
very quick we turn around the contract
usually same day get in their hands
a week two weeks three weeks
and what happens is there's internal
pressure because these teams have to hit
quarterly quotas sure
the external companies they don't give a
[__] about your quota they're going
through their process right right and so
one of the things that we've tried
sometimes with success sometimes not is
to just be honest and say hey for
internal purposes like getting this done
by the end of the quarter would be
really powerful for us like how do we
get that done yep literally sometimes
I've seen people respond back and be
like so what right like I don't care
yeah but other times I have seen them
say okay let us see what we can try to
get done sure how do you see kind of
quarterly quotas and like the internal
pressure yep is that a tool to be used
externally or is it actually something
that could hurt people when they start
to kind of you know pull back the
curtain and explain some of like the
internal uh you know inner workings and
and they're just like I don't give a
[__] yeah
um that's a great question and I think
it depends how how you use it right so
there's a little bit of finesse on how
you say it in a sense of like hey
um you know I have goals
um and our quarter is you know done at
the end of this week
um I don't want to be pushy but you know
help me understand you think is real
that we can get this done by Friday if
not I completely understand but I just
want to make sure that you know I
forecast this accordingly and they'll
understand you know and if you have a
good enough of a relationship like I
think that that you can you can do that
what doesn't work is if you come out of
left field then you haven't talked to
them in a while and say like hey you
know the quarter ends today do you think
we can get this done like you're you're
probably actually hurting the deal in
that case because it's like dude you're
it's about self-interest but you have
that good enough of a relationship where
you can be you know subtle about it I
think uh you can get the answer that
you're looking for got it that makes
sense
um let's talk about kind of your
transition right you were inside some of
the fastest growing companies in the
country in terms of startups uh
absolutely wild places people have heard
a ton of stuff about them talk a little
bit about those experiences really uh
kind of from the sales perspective and
like you know what were the lessons that
you learned and maybe what are some of
the things you're like okay you know if
I go to the next business we're not
going to recreate some of the these
other things yeah so listen I appreciate
you bringing that up I I've been part of
yeah three unicorns uh zenefits Rippling
and wework and I have too many lessons
uh from each of them
um and and starting with zenefits
zenefits in 2014 was the fastest growing
uh B2B SAS company in the world uh we
did zero to uh 72 million dollars in
about two and a half years and it was
really like building a plain mid-flight
as some of the leadership would describe
it and you just learn how to operate
fast effectively right there's there's
you have to put in work around you know
the performance just like a performer as
I think sales are you know kind of
performers in a certain extent but at
zenefits I was an environment where I
had anywhere between 10 to 12 uh net new
customer demos a day for for years and
you learn about a lot about selling you
learn a lot about you know kind of
trusting yourself but you know you start
paying attention
to the company into the business my
background's in finance so I I kind of
had a different perspective from like a
financial perspective and in 2014 there
was a growth at all cost mentality that
may or may not have been sustainable as
you and I know
um and it was it was sad because uh
zenefits was a very uh boom bust uh
situation the company you know after
growing aggressively becoming a unicorn
in such a short period of time
um ended up having you know a lot of
problems with like sales growth and we
ended up having to lay off a lot of the
team and and that was hurtful
the lesson there is you know kind of
operate effectively but you know kind of
keep going
um and then of course you know
everything that I know to from B2B SAS
like I learned there and having a big
exposure to building stuff and talking
to the engineering team now the second
uh unicorn that I went to was Rippling I
was the first sales hire of the company
uh exactly what we were just discussing
uh working for Parker Conrad who's a
great friend
um and I was sitting in his basement
with 12 engineers and we had one SDR and
you learn how to have a lot of
conviction but you learn how to put
yourself in a situation where you have
to wear every single hat that you can
think of and pull every trick out of
your hat that you've used throughout
your career right there's nothing
structured so you have to be okay with
uncertainty and know that it's going to
be okay but also you know be very
organized about the things that you do
because you have to think about Revenue
generating time but you also have to
think about building at the same time
and then the third company I went to
um was wework which I thought was a very
safe bet at the time
um incredible story experience maybe for
another time but
um wework was also a high growth
environment and I kind of realized and
you know looking back that I've I've had
a lot of success by saying yes to
opportunities that a lot of people have
said no to and we were brought me to
Miami actually Miami in 2018 was a
distressed Market in the eyes of wework
because not a lot of big companies
wanted to set up their headquarters here
and I signed up for it and you know the
lesson there is you know I was willing
to you know kind of get my hands dirty
stand up a team recruit the right team
to sell from Miami and then eventually I
ended up you know growing my
responsibilities to run sales for the
southeast of the United States
and that was a very different
environment from my experience from
selling B2B SAS deals that ranged
anywhere from 50 to 250k to going we
were the average contract value was
anywhere between two and five million
dollars so very different stages very
different
um you know kind of experiences and
products but uh common lessons you know
in terms of sales and like the right
things to do uh which you know I carry
with me for for all my career how did
you decide to leave kind of doing sales
for other people to go start your own
business
I always knew I wanted to be an
entrepreneur but I also noticed
something that was very unique which was
I have a very unique exposure and
experience that a lot of people want
access to and that I could make a
business out of coming from like my
business background I I always think
about Hedges and not putting all your
eggs in one basket and their
reciprocation and I sort of build that
structure with my company now that's
called quota in a way where I can work
with different companies I can give them
the value that I bring to the table
given my experience but I'm not putting
all my eggs in that one basket and maybe
it's a protection for my own self given
my past experiences at zenefits and
wework which didn't necessarily end how
I wanted them to end right and
I I knew that you know as a founding
account executive you're such an
entrepreneur because you're doing so
many things that if I were to apply it
all those to starting my own business I
would have been successful and so far
it's been an incredible experience and
then talk to me about uh you kind of
have to do sales for yourself to then go
help people with sales right so it's
like this like very interesting kind of
meta type thing
um but where have you found uh the best
channels to get customers like how have
you apply some of your lessons that you
know from these other businesses to your
own business now that's a great question
and we touched on it lightly earlier but
there are three channels let's say that
worked for me really well from the top
of the funnel perspective which I wish
like every rep would know or would
utilize a lot more number one's
referrals right so you know I I work
with companies that you know I do a good
job they refer me to other customers and
I ask for the referral and that you know
kind of comes uh I come highly
recommended so I have like a pretty
close good close rate on those uh
referrals number two is your network
right so there's there's a people call
it the go to network and the go to
network is pretty much like you know
where throughout your experience and
your life you know have you made you
know relationships that you can you know
knock on their door and say like hey
here's what I'm doing like how do we
work together
um and then the third one is content so
I like to talk a lot about content I've
been talking a lot about content lately
because what I realize is that sales is
taking a page out of you know
marketing's book and it's almost
becoming where like a lot of B2B sales
motions are becoming b2c sales motions
and I'll explain because you know
typically you would see people marketing
their product online or doing all this
content online uh just to sell like a
particular like you know let's say
e-commerce product but now you're
starting to see a lot of B2B folks doing
the same creating content on LinkedIn
sharing a lot of value sharing their
experiences uh doing it even through
Twitter doing it even through you know
kind of Instagram and I started to embed
a lot in that time and obviously through
like being well organized with creating
content on one side and then running the
operation on the other side I found a
lot of success and interestingly enough
I never had to do outbound for my
business
and so when you're going to like let's
say the network as an example how much
of this is uh hey here's everything I do
versus let me just have a conversation
with this person listen sure right and
then kind of uh see where you can almost
um you know help sure and that helping
is really where the business gets
inserted like is it this like
intentional like that's a company I want
to work with them here's exactly what
I'm going to do for them like let me go
talk to them yeah or is it much more
like that seems like a business that uh
is gonna going to continue to grow let
me go talk to them learn about all their
problems and then I'll come to them with
a proposal for like how I could be
helpful that um it's it's more of like I
try to be
very prescriptive when I asked for
something so I know I know my expertise
and so for example if I see a B2B SAS
company that's series a that's doing
good
um and then I think that they could be
doing better I'll try to you know kind
of study up the company and find a
mutual connection and then say like hey
I think this company like could benefit
from my work
um the other thing that I'll mention
that I forgot to mention which is really
important a big referral partner for me
is VCS so I work very closely with VCS
for a handful of reasons first of all I
mean you get a lot of exposure
one-to-many in terms of like getting
access to their portfolio but not every
BC has an internal sales expert a lot of
VCS have very sophisticated uh operators
Builders people that have been more on
the technical side of the business but
don't necessarily have like that
commercial element so I come and sort of
sit on their bench and act as a you know
kind of sales expert for those companies
which end up you know kind of work
working really well because when a VC is
funding a company and they tell you like
hey go talk to Javier it's almost like
the person that's giving you money is
telling you to do something you're
probably gonna go do it right yeah that
makes uh that makes a lot of sense what
would you say is uh the biggest mistake
that Founders make when it comes to
sales whether it's them doing the sales
hiring managing the teams like what's
like the one thing you're like if I
could just take have everyone take
something away from this conversation
please don't do X yeah well I mean
there's one that's super obvious which
is like don't build products that people
don't want right because listen pump at
the end of the day there's a lot of
people that build products that you know
they forced the distribution and like if
the market doesn't want it like you're
not going to have any type of product
Market fit or repeatability so I think
that the way to solve for that is you
know front load your sales and what I
mean by that is like start talking to
people as many as you can imagine that
you're doing the sales process get
feedback and understand what people are
struggling with or what they're doing
um and you know I I've you know kind of
experimented with an AI product
ourselves that we're looking to you know
add to our services or sell individually
and what we've done is talk to hundreds
of people and I don't know that a lot of
Founders will do that on a regular basis
to say like hey let me talk to 100
companies run it like a sales process
get feedback and then build something
that the market wants because then when
you start talking about it and building
content and you know kind of doing the
prospecting
once the product is built you're
actually responding to like a true need
versus like a need that is perceived
from just your own perspective so talk
to more people ahead of time is is
pretty much what I would recommend where
can we send people to find you on the
internet or find out more about quota
um so I'm very active on LinkedIn
um so Javier Ramirez Lugo is where you
can find me and on Twitter Javi B2B is
uh my handle so you can find me there
I'm I'm uh very pretty clear what you do
pretty clear what I do so uh yeah you
can check out anything that I'm doing
and the companies that I'm working with
there awesome thank you so much for
doing this uh I always learned something
about sales every single time we talk
and anyone who's looking to learn more
uh I highly suggest they reach out to
you so I appreciate it thank you for the
time pop super exciting